when we look at all these different
kinds of shapes mainly different kinds
of trials and different kinds of
quadrilaterals so far right these shapes
are different these shapes are different
and they are very very special I mean do
you member how we looked at just a
random quadrilateral any color okay you
make it completely unmatching no
parallel or equal sides or anything like
that and yet still do you remember the
construction I showed you what was the
construction I showed you if you join up
all the midpoints of the sides you're
gonna get magically every single time
you get a parallelogram and I find that
mildly creepy okay so you're getting all
these special properties coming out of
even seemingly random shapes now a
circle is about as non-random as you can
guess right it's like well it's it's
perfect isn't it right in every sense of
the word which is why what you have look
at this sheet in front of you when I
first um had that job or about
memorizing these laws and I dutifully
put it I'll I here's a tip for you this
is what I do it's probably not a good
thing that was so effective for me but
anyway I get anything I need to memorize
and I laminate it and then I stick it up
in my shower okay because you're
standing there you're probably probably
enjoy long showers in winter too much
but anyhow I was there standing and you
end up looking at thing you like what
else am I gonna do here right so it's a
psych get out of the shower I really up
to property 18 anyway so so what I did
was I put there but I found this very
very dry I was given the UM the list of
properties there are more by the way but
this is just the main set and they're
much the once you get that most fun with
I was given these I wasn't given these
in exactly the same form that I've given
them to you and I hope you'll see why
there's some structure to this and this
list became kind of for me in the bag of
everything I hated about
mathematics it's just good memorizes
Sabini with things and then regurgitate
they've had a later time we will assess
your ability to regurgitate them
accurately and that frustrated me a lot
and mathematics like this is still lit
like this okay but here's the way I want
to put two differently you see how that
this court you letter right this random
court you lateral
it still has you know some special
properties it can't help it okay being
that a circle is so so so special it's
almost like every line you draw every
angle you form anything you do you make
something special that's how unique this
shape is okay because of how special it
is you can't help discover properties
about it and that's what this list is
about that's why this list is so
enormous right it's like oh I just drew
a random line and it happened to do
something awesome in my circle okay so
before we get to these and I'll let you
have the opportunity to spend maybe five
ten minutes as we talk through this just
try and see if you can work out there
there is a clear structure so this is by
the way structure is another tip for
when you're trying to memorize something
that's long trying to think okay can i
grip these into meaningful categories
because they are grouped in categories
I've drawn myself a big circle and maybe
you want to draw one largest circle cut
from your smaller ones because we want
to just get out our language and that's
have an ology together right so we can
describe this circle so most important
part of a circle it's the center
ironically the most important part of a
circle is not part of the surface okay
so the set up obviously the reason why
it's so important is because it defines
the circle right how would you define a
circle
okay cool so generally the most calmer
definition of a circle will win you when
you're young that's it's a round thing I
wanted to be around but a more technical
definition which stands up to
mathematical rigour is it's the set of
points and there's a different set of
them it's the set of points that are all
equidistant from one central point which
we call the center all right give me
another important feature it's the only
one I've already got there which is this
color okay that length around okay the
next one that I heard was a cord I will
put the cord on but surely is a more
important one than that right the radius
thank you okay the radius of course it
applies another important line is the
diameter you're doing
and that leads me to what was mentioned
before which is that the diameter is a
special kind of line in the circle I
should say putable because it joins two
points of the circumference which makes
it a accord okay
now by the way just as I'm going through
this I hope you can see I'll try to do
the same thing right I'm trying to
rather just give you a list of pieces in
random order they all kind of that there
is an order to the pieces in this shape
right when you have a center that
implies a radius which gives you this
circumference and the radius of course
is part of that another Rock so where
would you go next for the chord aren't
you going to next
I would I would probably go cuz I
already have the circumference here
right this chord it blocks off part of
the circumference I'm gonna need another
color here and you if you have one you
do as well so down the bottom here right
I have this this curved part here is an
arc like it's worth mentioning because I
said the chord cuts off a part of the
circumference right that's not
technically true is it in fact it cuts
off too doesn't it do you see that every
chord is going to do that it might
because I've drawn it all the way down
here there's one arc which is clearly
smaller and one arc which is clearly
larger so we call them any guesses like
the minor arc down here this would be
the minor arc and these of the guy would
be the major arc okay it's a little bit
like when you describe an angle if I
said to you
if I said to you angle ABC right angle
ABC that you default by looking at this
thing on the right hand side right but
of course that's only one of the angles
that's defined by ABC there's another
one what do we call it you'd have to
call it reflex angle ABC so it tends to
be the default that if I said okay here
is a chord I'm gonna call it PQ I'm
gonna call it P Q the chord PQ it closes
off an arc we generally mean the minor
arc just like we would say you generally
means I will be the next feature that
you see it's already on there I've
already drawn it on in between the chord
and the arc I have an area right why
it's pretty small okay so let's go right
in this this is a segment okay just as
with the arc it would excuse me the
chord blocks off two segments there's a
small one and then there's a bigger one
- segment major segment okay
closely related to the segment yeah oh
yeah okay good the next area like I'm
thinking areas then I'm gonna draw this
guy Irvine yeah so if I block off a
piece of pie like that okay this guy is
a you see what I did um that's a sector
sector we've got a pretty healthy set
there what are we missing
what other things would we add from
there because my kind of like where does
go for it
I think we're gonna have to now start
going outside the circle okay on things
that are inside the circle we've pretty
much covered those but if you just go
just a little bit not quiet I'm gonna
draw this guy now if it's our line goes
on forever
and it just touches this circumference
we cost for that a tangent because
tangent like the word tangible it means
it just touches right we've talked about
that before
yep okay so if you've got your tangent
thank you and rather touching at one
point it touches it too it slices
straight across like a man's latex I
could I could just extend the cord but I
don't want to confuse the two together
just like the radius of the day so I'm
gonna draw it over here that's the
secret cuts across by the way you should
ask a very important question which is
that our for secant at least and
possibly not likely potato but for both
the words teacher and seeker
this another meaning attached to each of
these words we reuse them right we reuse
them in trigonometry right in fact we
need two of the six basic functions
after these two features you should ask
why that's not a coincidence right
mathematicians clearly have no problems
inventing new words right so why would
they repurpose a used word in auditory
something which seems have nothing to do
with this clearly you know it doesn't
have nothing to do this but what does
have to do